our people caduceus a king for the hosel
will ensure mice bought out to do holy
this is what I can only assume is a
grasshopper monk priests team she's on a
comment ah it doesn't crunch you like
sink into it they taste very stale a lot
like Corn Pops it also looks like a bag
of teeth but I can't stop eating on
pisaq I would get ecology pickled ah de
Parfum in a single bar open what the
Kentucky this fall you don't need to
speak Portuguese to know what that means
it's love baby it looks like a like a
hotel bar of soap smells something nut
buttery it looks like dust which is fine
sometimes that's all you want it tastes
good it's a terrible form look at that
this is good
alright Brazil pull by email taped it
all come with you shouldn't you dig wet
enough this is tutti fruity flavored
that's not a real fruit though this
smells like Red Bull flavor is that what
uh that's what the kid is isn't that
listen like energy drinks oh yeah I was
like a sugar bomb with my mouth I mean
it's good I don't really know what to
say
Brazil is inhaling it this is great Kiko
no podía - RTC a gesture circulation ah
brigadeiro plated balls
mmm Chavo ball look like little poops
it's so good these are microwaved just
tastes like hot chocolate but it does
look like - well poop poop that
microwave we gon point ah whatever this
is I don't want to eat it it smells
really good
this is apparently gelatin made from cow
hooves nice and how sweet
wait actually how is that even like a
food most gelatin is made from bone
stuff oh that's not good
it's really good
Oh